it's our show's tradition actually to
spend this holiday with the same two
guests year after year who we absolutely
love and adore and the whole planet
loves them as far as I'm concerned yeah
let's do it please welcome back to the
show astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson
and
hi hi
and the birthday boy himself
environmental and lifestyle expert Danny
because we are we are at a round of
Earth stay trivia Showdown
[Applause]
okay I love that we do this every year
Neil you know you've come this is your
third time playing this on Earth Day and
little known fact you have lost every
single time
I came for a participation Trophy this
time all right
explain the rules this is our third year
but how does it work well it's simple
each correct answer is worth one point
and you must wait until I or Drew have
read the entire question and the
multiple choice options before hitting
your buzzer the contestant with the most
points wins our coveted Earth Day trophy
I do love our trophies
look at that
but the winner doesn't only get that
beautiful trophy they also get a hundred
trees planted in a designated U.S
national forest in their honor question
number one we all use a lot of paper
products but if you add up all the wood
paper and paper products the average
American uses in one year how many full
trees would that equal would it be a
Seven Trees B one tree or C 15 trees
okay
I thought so too but the answer is any
guy says Danny I'm gonna go with seven
you would have been correct seven full
trees also I don't get the point uh no
oh okay no points on the board yet it's
anybody's game next to each of you is a
recycling bin you each have 15 seconds
to pick out the three items inside your
bin that cannot be recycled 15 seconds
on the clock go
all right they're digging through what
cannot be recycled it's it's filled with
all sorts of things you have eight
seconds remaining eight seconds
five seconds left pull out the three
items you think cannot because I go one
time's up
okay so what did you pick I picked this
this juice container uh-huh a coat
hanger and then I don't know what this
is all right great guess
[Laughter]
aerosol hanger and styrofoam well guess
what one of you is correct and that
person is Danny
one point for you uh styrofoam is not
recyclable okay do that dance one more
time what was that it's it's
that's how he celebrate yeah styrofoam
you can't um recycle styrofoam no you
cannot it doesn't biodegrade in the
landfills and then aerosol cans and wire
hangers they are used of metal but the
pressurized contents of the cans and the
shape of the hanger means they could
actually damage the recycling machines
interesting right and depressing and now
we're going live to the Sun for our next
question
yes hello yes it's me the sun I'm very
busy let's get to this okay question how
much of the US is powered by solar
energy is it 8.6 B 3.4 or C 12.3 percent
you guys get a lot of big stars around
here huh what about this I'm the biggest
one
I gotta go I'm busy bloated too oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
you got
it all
and just like that
we got one we've got a tie right now we
are tired oh this is anybody's game
this is exciting but we come prepared
with a tiebreaker question whoever gets
this right wins the whole thing so
listen carefully choosing a bike over a
car for just one day reduces the average
person's carbon emissions from
Transportation by how much is it a 67 B
100 or C 88 percent
Danny going with a hundred
incorrect it's 67 yeah that is really
good we also know one other thing that
we have a tie that we have a tie and
you're both going to win Neil the streak
has been broken
[Applause]
and you will share custody of this
beautiful trophy
also I just released this album it's uh
Drew Barrymore sings the blues featuring
the number one hit I dream of drift
which is my favorite stain removal spray
and they have such Classics as uh you
know run run Rossi that's a great one
these are the only copies of these hours
thank you Daddy and Neil and you guys be
sure to check out Neil's new book Starry
Messenger and it's available now we'll
be right back
[Music]
foreign